this building you're looking at looks
like a regular building except it's
called geneva freeport it's in
switzerland it holds roughly 1.2 million
art pieces valued at ready a hundred
billion dollars many of the art pieces
in there are owned by millionaires and
billionaires around the world who have
never seen the art they've never touched
it but they store it here the question
is why and by the way
art historically has known as being the
top three most unregulated industries in
the world behind drugs
and sex prostitution but why are so many
investors billionaires millionaires
buying art why are they doing that we're
going to take a deep dive in that topic
today
[Music]
so here's what we're going to be talking
about we're going to talk about the pros
and cons of investing into art who the
players are how big of a market is it
what are the most expensive pieces the
history of the players and then at the
same time how do people value art how do
you look at a piece and say i think this
thing's worth three million dollars
we're going to talk about all that today
so first thing we need to know is what
is the market cap like how much business
is really being done with art last year
in u.s we saw 28 billion dollars of art
just last year grow by third second
place was china at 13.4 billion third
place was uk at 11.3 billion the last 18
years
the top 100 artists have so their return
has been roughly 8.9 while the s p has
been roughly 3.4 so these are some of
the data now there is no guarantees with
art there's a lot of good stories
there's a lot of bad stories there's a
lot of ugly stores i'll share a couple
of them here with you one of them is
imagine buying
an art piece that you sell
in 2005 for ten thousand dollars and
that art piece 12 years later sells for
you ready
450 million dollars that's this art
piece here you're looking at called
salvator mundi here's what you need to
know about the story of salvator mundi
so this art piece back in 1958 sotheby's
had it they looked at it like okay it's
great they sold it for 45 pounds not 45
000 pounds just 45 pounds in 1958 years
later in o5 in a louisiana auction it
sold for ten thousand dollars then
eventually they restored it they looked
at it they said wait a minute this was
an art piece that was owned by henrietta
maria who was the wife of king charles
the first of england and the story is in
2011 it was included in the leonardo
exhibition at the national gallery in
london the show's curator authenticated
it as a long-lost leonardo da vinci
recorded in the collection of again
henrietta maria having said that the
moment that happened and it was
validated and backed by a prestigious
museum it was sold to a swiss
businessman yves bouvier in 2013 for 80
million dollars then the same year he
flipped it to russian businessman dmitry
rybolov for 127.5 million dollars and
then in 2017 it sold for 450 million
dollars to an anonymous name some say to
saudi prince again this is a rumor that
the saudi prince bought it however what
is not a rumor is the fact that this
thing was sold for 45 pounds by
sotheby's and 58. 10 000
at a auction in louisiana in 2005 450
million dollars in 2017 those numbers
are real so that's a good story that's a
success story let me give you an ugly
story about art so back in the days
picasso is not doing too well he doesn't
have a lot of living to do there's a
local con man that's selling art fake
art so he goes to local artists and says
hey
i got this art piece i want you to draw
similar to picasso style and the kid had
a picasso style a painting so he does he
takes it he says you know picasso
there's this young guy that really
admires you would you mind if i bring it
over to you i want you to look at it and
give me feedback tell me if this guy's
got some potential or not picasso
finally apparently agrees to meet with
him they do
and says yeah this is not really a good
piece he says man that's so
disappointing can i take a picture with
you he does he has the picture with him
and picasso and the painting picasso
dies again this is a story i've read and
then later on this guy the con man sells
the art piece saying this is the last
art piece picasso painted and people
bought into it because he had the
picture so there's a lot of that
creativity where there is con there's
fraud there's a lot of that going on
because it is the most unregulated
industry in the world however those are
some of the stories you need to know
about now in america when you look at
the top you know uh um
auction houses how are they doing at the
top you have sotheby's that did roughly
7.3 billion last year they have offices
in 40 plus countries they're known for
selling the andy warhol's orange
maryland monroe in 98 for 17.3 million
but they also sold edward munich's
masterpiece to scream for
record-breaking
119.9 million dollars at the time and
then you have christie's christie's
7.1 billion last year they were the ones
that actually sold people's you know nft
for 69 million dollars they have 85
offices in 43 countries in 2016 they
auctioned off rockefeller's collection
which was a record-breaking sale that
they did i think was
832 million dollars so they're second
place and in third place is heritage
auctions i bought a lot of different
things from them many i'm talking
millions of dollars of pieces from these
guys last year they did 1.2 billion
dollars they're based out of uh texas
some of the things that they do they
could do anything from a car to a car
card to a art piece to comic books the
variety of things that they do and the
last one being phillips phillips at
fourth place at 1.2 billion dollars so
again when you look at this you may say
pat i know nothing about this well most
people get into our don't know nothing
about this but there are 6 300 auction
houses worldwide for a reason and there
is a reason why art in the last 18 years
has nearly tripled the returns on s p
500 this doesn't guarantee it's going to
continue doing this but it is an
alternative investment that a lot of
people are getting into so now the
question becomes how do you value art
because when you value a house what's
the realtor gonna say appraise it
they're gonna say well that house same
size as you with the bedroom with the
same lot so far 628. that one sold for
639 that one sold for 648 your house is
roughly worth 631 because there's cops
in art there's not really comps there's
many different ways of value and art
we're going to talk about that right now
number one supplying demand is there a
market for do people want to buy it
number two is it sold privately or at an
auction house if it sells at an auction
house the auction house of christie's
when christie said they're selling
people's nft everybody was like wait
what there was 33 people at the end
above a million dollars that were
bidding for this nft but christie's in a
way validated that nfts are now a thing
so anytime a big auction house comes
behind an artist the value that artists
and their pieces goes higher number
three artists there's some artists that
you know people are fascinated by i'll
give you one example banksy
is a anonymous artist that nobody knows
who he is there's some claims of who he
is but nobody knows really who banks is
he pulled off one of the biggest stunts
at an auction so the auction's over with
somebody bits on his piece for 1.4
million dollars the moment they hit the
hammer the art piece starts ripping
apart at the bottom
people are flabbergasted you should see
the reaction of people like wait a
minute what just happened here that's
and then and embanks he puts it on his
instagram and he says going going gone
well don't worry and don't feel bad for
the guy that bought it for 1.4 million
sotheby's has a back on auction right
now for 25 million dollars it's shredded
and people are willing to pay 25 million
dollars for a shredded art piece again
there's the artist that's attractive
that people say i want a piece by this
guy number four career and size of
artwork meaning you know what was his
courier like is he still producing is
there a limited amount is it is the
artist dead many times when the artist
dies the art piece goes more because he
can't produce it they can't make any
more of it so career and size of artwork
also determines the value of the art
piece who supports it and who's owned it
if a major name buys an art piece and
they say barack obama just recently
bought this this this elon musk just
bought this art piece and you know like
i'll go to wynwood in miami and many of
the places i'll go to they'll say this
art piece was also about by elamas jeff
bezos donald trump and barack obama like
oh wow there's credibility behind it
with pictures of individuals who bought
that art piece there's some credibility
and valuation on pieces goes high the
beauty is in the eye to beholder what
does this mean you know how they say
there's always somebody for somebody and
you look at someone you say i cannot
believe
she married him what
it doesn't matter she sees something
that you don't see the beauty is in the
eye to behold whoever wants to buy that
art piece i've seen some art pieces i'll
stand in front of an art piece and i'll
look and i say i am so confused i'll say
what was this person on when they
painted this thing and another person is
standing next to me but i'm not saying
my thoughts out loud and i hear them say
what an incredible piece it doesn't
matter what i think this person thinks
it's incredible they're willing to pay
six hundred thousand dollars for it it's
a six hundred thousand thousand art
piece sentimental and cultural value
what does this mean it could be a piece
that has to do with your heritage your
background your meaning you see
something that has to do with your
heritage you say well this is worth a
half a million to me but twenty thousand
dollars to this person doesn't matter
because it's value to me i'm gonna buy
this i'm gonna pay for this so there's
some value to it another one could be a
piece that was stolen many years ago 20
30 40 years ago 50 years ago and now all
of a sudden it's showing back up wait a
minute this thing's been gone for 50
years we thought it was completely gone
it's not resurfaced i'm willing to pay
xyz dollars for it so again it may not
be the traditional way to get a comp of
value in something but that's how they
value art pieces in that industry
picasso once was in a park and a lady
comes up with you know and says hey can
you make this portrait of me and within
a few minutes he draws a portrait and
says here you go 5 000 francs the lady's
like wait what 5 000 francs it took you
a couple minutes to paint this thing
here it says no madam it took me a
lifetime to learn how to do this year
5000 francs the artist
who has spent a lifetime learning how to
do this
gets to ask for the price because it
wasn't just a five minute ten minute
piece like the engineer comes in and
says hey you know can you please fix my
ac it's not working and he goes and he
says yes that one button they press the
ac is not working they said 600 why am i
paying 600 i could have done it myself
yeah but you don't know which switch it
is that's a form of being an artist
today sponsors masterworks matter of
fact i really like what masterworks does
because a lot of people can't afford to
buy a whole art piece for two million
dollars what masterworks does is they
buy the art piece they file it with the
sec
then members are able to buy and sell
shares that's what they do now keep in
mind you know this is like you can't buy
all of apple for two and a half trillion
dollars but you can buy an apple stock
for a few hundred dollars similar story
one thing you need to know about how
much wealth is being held in art today
is an estimated 1.7 trillion dollars
millionaires billionaires have helped
their wealth and art deloitte says it's
going to increase another 900 billion
dollars by 2026. what masterworks does
is the last five paintings they sold
since 2017 their average rate of return
was 26.8 percent and contemporary art
prices have outperformed s p 500 total
return ready by 164 percent the past 26
years so if this is something you want
to take advantage of we're going to put
the link below there is a waiting list
for people that are trying to get into
this program with master works but
because you're part of valuetainment if
you click on the link below and you go
through the item you will skip the
waiting list and you'll be able to start
buying and selling shares immediately
now let's talk about the pros and cons
of investing in art let's start off with
cons first number one when you buy an
art piece there is no dividends for you
you're just buying an art piece it's not
like every
quarter or every you're gonna get some
kind of a dividend payment number two
you need a lot of money to get into it
it's not a business you get into with
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
you need some money to really get into
the art industry number three there are
a lot of fake and forged paintings out
there that you need the right people
verifying it to make sure you're not
buying it and it's worth nothing you
know how you do that if you're newer in
the industry
you may be taking advantage of at times
number four if you do choose to store it
in your house if you damage the piece or
your kids damage it or somebody damages
it the value obviously goes down
investing is a gamble just like anything
if you go into an industry you know
nothing about it is purely a gamble so
it's going to take you a minute or a few
years to learn the industry before you
start making some money next art is not
as liquid as you know stocks and mutual
funds you can sell some of those it's
not as easy to sell an art piece at the
price that you want to sell it at next
sometimes a great art salesman can sell
you piece because they're so charming
and charismatic but that piece is not
really worth that much so you got to
kind of be careful with the sales person
as well okay so now let's talk about
some pros number one it's an asset class
that has grown
exponentially in the recent years so you
ought to take a look at it number two it
is a hedge against inflation there are a
lot of pieces where inflation is going
up if they're no longer reprinting or
drawing this piece and that piece is
fifty 50 000 today and inflation keeps
going up that is a form of a hedge
against inflation next a form of
diversification if you got all your
money in one thing and you're not a
hedging yet against you know other
alternative classes this may be a form
of diversifying some of your investments
next pro if you buy it it becomes scarce
something happens that's going to go up
in value anything scares nowaday cards
cars painting comic books value is going
to eventually go up next if you actually
like art there is a certain experience
when you go into a house and there's art
pieces there i was looking at a house in
palm beach with a realtor who was
selling donald trump's last house one of
the houses he had in palm beach it was
asking for 140 or 145 145 million and i
went in there and i'm looking at the
house i'm like oh wow so many art pieces
he says this is my art collection 70
million dollars worth of art collection
he had in there i said are you selling a
house are you selling art he says kind
of both do you want to buy any of the
art pieces if you don't want to buy the
house but the point is when somebody
comes into a house to a house and
there's an art piece there there's a
story behind it so that that idea of
explaining let me tell you the history
about this art there are some tax
incentives to owning art you know like
you heard the story earlier
rockefeller's 2016
832.6 million dollars when they sold
their art collection to charity
they can give it to charity but maybe
that art collection when they bought it
was only 40 million dollars and now it's
worth 832. that's a big write-off right
there because the valuation is the
valuation so there's also tax incentives
when it comes down to art of course not
an accountant not a cpa talk to an
expert about that but many do it for the
tax benefits as well and last but not
least you can actually make some money
in this business uh it's not guaranteed
there's a lot of risk but you can
actually make some money in the art
business so if you got value out of this
video and something's maybe you didn't
know about give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel and i got another video i
want you to watch this video i don't
know how many maybe three years ago i
shot this video about my millionaire
card collection that i had at the time
today it's more like eight to ten
million
but it shows how this thing works i
bought two cards great gretzky cards at
540 000
year and a half later i sold it roughly
for 2.2 million
it was a world record for the most
expensive hockey card ever sold
one of the cars that i sold for 1.29
million dollars with heritage auctions
six months later sold roughly for 3.7
million dollars if i would have hung on
to those two cards that i spent 540
today both of them combined today would
be roughly around five to six million
dollars that's the part about
alternative investments there's many
different things you can look into if
you're interested take a look at this
video take care everybody bye bye
you